wir brauchen keine zusätzliche
zündschnur im nahen osten so der
deutsche außenminister heiko maas
gestern im bundestag bei der debatte um
den atomstreit zwischen dem iran und den
usa
international wächst die sorge über die
lage am persischen golf
washington erhöht seine militärische
präsenz der iran ist nicht bereit zu
verhandeln können die europäer
vermitteln und die krise entschärfen usa
contra iran eskaliert der konflikt das
ist das thema der phoenix runde
phoenix runde schon gut ich begrüße sie
ganz herzlich aus berlin ja wir
diskutieren über diesen konflikt
zwischen den usa und dem iran
und das sind meine gäste ard serie hat
ist bei uns expertin für den nahen und
mittleren osten der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik herzlich
willkommen eric kirschbaum freie
amerikanischer journalist viele jahre
für reuters aus europa berichtet jetzt
schreibt die los angeles times
und ich begrüße tim guldimann schweizer
diplomat von 1999 bis 2004 waren sie
botschafter in teheran im iran und haben
in der zeit auch die amerikanischen
interessen wahrgenommen und herzlich
willkommen georg mascolo leiter des
recherche verbundes von ndr wdr und die
deutsche zeitung und auch für den
spiegel korrespondent in washington vor
samuel hat wenn man sich das jetzt
anschaut viele schauen mit großer sorge
auf diese entwicklung wie gefährlich ist
der iran denn für die usa
aber die frage ist ja eigentlich was hat
iran für kapazitäten tatsächlich und
wenn wir uns anschauen die entwicklung
der letzten jahre dann sehen wir dass
iran geopolitisch in der region heute
stärker ist als je zuvor in der
geschichte der islamischen republik aber
dass sich das bedrohungspotenzial und
die bedrohungs wahrnehmung eigentlich
irans kein stück verändert hat und dass
es durchaus eine sehr gefährliche
kombination und in diesem zusammenhang
sehen wir dass diese politik des
maximalen drucks aus der usa eigentlich
genau diese bedrohung spreads aktion
irans bestätigt die sehr weit verbreitet
ist innerhalb der iranischen führung und
dazu führt dass ihren die kapazitäten
dies in der region habt nutzen will um
vorbereitet zu sein auf eine mögliche
militärische eskalation
das heißt nicht dass iran selbst auf
eine direkte militärische eskalation
gesetzt da wäre er noch in einer
deutlich schwächeren position aber das
heißt schon dass iran die kapazitäten
die ist in den letzten jahren gerade in
der region aufgebaut hat gerade mit
blick auf seinen netzwerk an
nichtstaatlichen akteuren vom irak über
syrien bis zum libanon
vielleicht auch verstärkt einsetzen
könnte wenn es zu einer größeren
eskalation käme und also durchaus
sorgenvoll schauen sie da auch hin
sorgen vor mit blick auf das potenzial
einer eskalation mit sicherheiten und
ich muss jetzt einfach mal nachfragen
sie sagen iran viele sagen der iran was
ist eigentlich richtig sie können
getrost auf den artikel verzicht okay
gut dann haben wir das auch noch mal
gelernt haben uns das auch heute noch
mal gemerkt haben der kirschbaum welche
warum fühlen sich die usa bedroht ja
nicht nur die usa ist für ihre vielen
ländern da in der region vier und
bedroht waren hat lange gearbeitet diese
atomwaffen und unterstützt die aktuellen
gegen die beiden akteure sind und das
hat dazu geführt dass trump diese halte
kurs führt und jetzt hat er dazu ist ein
hardliner john porter der seit 20 jahren
krieg irgendwie gegen iran führen will
ja das ist nicht unbedingt das einkommen
muss zurückgekommen will man heute auch
gesagt dass er wird nicht in einen krieg
gezwungen werden
ja das ist doch nicht noch nicht soweit
denkt ich wichtig war ja dieses atom
abkommen was es was lange verhandelt
wurde herr coleman was viel gesagt haben
das ist endlich einen punkt wo wir
weiter sind dieses abkommen wurde von
den usa aufgekündigt und seitdem
eskaliert der konflikt noch mal
besonders sie als diplomat wie wichtig
ist dieses abkommen eigentlich dass da
gefunden wurde zwischen deutschland
frankreich china großbritannien und iran
es ist enorm wichtig vor allem deshalb
weil damals so etwas wie eine
internationale gemeinschaft funktioniert
und iran auch verhandlungsbereit war
und da hat man ein problem das schon
seit jahren um nicht zu sagen was
jahrzehnte existiert mit verhandlungen
gelöst und ich glaube es ist den letzten
jahren der größte durchbruch einer
internationalen multilateralen
verhandlung und ich bin nicht
einverstanden mit den akzenten die
gesetzt worden erstens iran sei nicht
verhandlungsbereit zweitens es besteht
ein bedrohungspotenzial aus iran und
drittens in den usa nimmt man ihre als
bedrohung wahr
ich meine wenn man das so ein führt
sieht man an sich eine situation
einseitig weil wenn man es schaut warum
wurde es eskaliert weil wichtigster
punkt war
trump hat das abkommen aufgeklärt
die aussage dass iran nicht
verhandlungsbereit er bezog sich darauf
dass der iranische außenminister heute
ein dialog mit den usa ausgeschlossen
hat ja natürlich wenn man von
amerikanischer seite zu ersten kriegs
ein flugzeugträger hinschickt ein
vertrag kündigt massiv droht und dran
damit john bolton der bekannt ist für
seine regime change politik und dann
glaubt jetzt machen sie einen deal unter
druck und dann sagt ihr sind sie nicht
bereit zu verhandeln ist schon eine
unterstellung die ziemlich kühn ist
mascolo wie würden sie ist ein
einschätzen wie gefährlich ist diese
situation da gerade und ist es so dass
es dass die das dadurch dass es die usa
dieses abkommen aufgekündigt haben dass
das das größte problem ist also mir
fehlt jede einschätzung wie gefährliches
im moment tatsächlich ist weil ich auch
glaube dass donald trump keinen konflikt
kein krieg für iran will ihn im grunde
auch nicht ich bin auch deshalb
vorsichtig weil wir ja kaum eine krise
erlebt haben wie die zwischen den usa
und iran
die schon so oft vor dem ausbruch stand
ich kann mich noch erinnern sich noch
korrespondent in den usa gewesen bin
wenn titel geschrieben über den
unvermeidlichen krieg und damals hat es
bevor es titel wurde eine lange
diskussion gegeben hin eigentlich ein
fragezeichen dahinter gehört oder nicht
und es ist dann am ende zum fragezeichen
gekommen aber es hat viele situationen
gegeben wo man tatsächlich dachte dass
dieser konflikt friedlich nicht mehr zu
lösen sein würde
was ist jetzt die unmittelbare ursache
für diese zuspitzung das ist ganz sicher
die kündigung des atom ab kommt von dem
man gleichzeitig sagen muss die europäer
haben sich das auch ein bisschen schöner
gewünscht als es tatsächlich gewesen ist
dieses atom abkommen hat präsident obama
unterschrieben aber es ist nie vom
kongress ratifizieren worden das ist es
war immer klar dies ist keine bindende
verpflichtung der usa sondern es ist
eine politische entscheidung des
damaligen präsidenten gewesen ist es in
den usa immer hoch umstritten gewesen
dazu kommt jetzt die sanktionspolitik
die iran ungeheuer unter druck setzt und
man muss sagen die hoffnung die viele
auch ich damit verbunden haben damals
mit dem atom abkommen dass es stück für
stück zu weiteren schritten kommen würde
zu einer wirtschaftlichen annäherung zu
gesprächen zur entspannung in der region
das alles hat sich nicht bewahrheitet
das heißt all diejenigen die darauf
gesetzt haben dass das atom abkommen
dass ich nach wie vor für gut und
richtig halte haben wir ein stück auch
ein einstieg sein könnte in
weitergehende diplomatische annäherung
das hat sich nicht bewahrheitet und im
iran gibt es seit vielen jahren eine
tiefsitzende enttäuschung weil sie sagen
das was uns versprochen worden ist
nämlich kein wirtschaftliches
entgegenkommen muss man sagen das haben
weder die usa noch die europäer bis
heute de einlösen können
dass amiri hat welches problem ist dass
wenn man sieht welche rolle spielen die
sanktionen die es ja jetzt gibt
gegenüber iran die die usa verhängt
haben also wie sehr schadet das dem land
wiegend wie merkt man dass im land die
sanktionen verschärfen im grunde
genommen probleme die iran selbst schon
hausgemacht in der eigenen wirtschaft
habt es gibt eine ganze reihe von
hausgemachten problemen darunter eine
sehr weit verbreitete korruption sehr
viel intransparenz sie haben bestimmte
nicht rechenschaft schuldig akteure in
der wirtschafts wäre die dort schalten
und walten können wie sie wollen
darunter religiöse stiftungen und
einigen unternehmen der
revolutionsgarden
es gibt eine ganze reihe von problemen
die iran von haus aus mitbringt aber die
derzeitige sanktionspolitik hat diese
probleme deutlich verschärft und wir
reden ja hier auch nicht mehr von
gezielten sanktionen dass es eine sehr
sehr breit angelegte sanktions kampagne
die sehr weitreichende folgen hat
innerhalb von acht monaten ist die
kaufkraft der iranischen bürger um fast
80 prozent zurückgegangen
die inflationsrate ist auch fast 40
prozent gestiegen das hat ganz
erhebliche konsequenzen für die bürger
wir sind auch in einer situation wo sich
unternehmen nicht nur nicht trauen
sanktionierte güter nach iran zu
exportieren sondern selbst nicht
funktionsfähige güter darunter
humanitäre güter das heißt wir haben
sogar probleme medizinische güter
lebensmittel pharmazeutische güter nach
iran zu exportieren das sind die
konsequenzen eines derartigen sanktions
regimes und das schlimme daran es im
grunde genommen und wir haben es eben
gehört die iranische bevölkerung selbst
hat ja im grunde genommen alles richtig
gemacht sie hat 2013 einen präsidenten
gewählt der sich für ein engagement mit
der westlichen staatengemeinschaft
eingesetzt habe dass ich für ein nuklear
kompromiss eingesetzt hat gerade weil
sie sich zwei sachen versprochen haben
eine wirtschaftliche verbesserung ihrer
lebensumstände und größere sicherheit
und vier jahre später sehen wie exakt
das gegenteil weniger sicherheit in der
es wäre und eine erhebliche
verschlechterung der wirtschaftlichen
lage
der gute mann ist das dann wie kommt man
daraus also wenn man sagt die sanktionen
haben solche konsequenzen solche folgen
für das land ist dass das interesse der
usa dahinter die iran so zu schwächen
dass das eigentliche interesse
offensichtlich und das macht die sache
außerordentlich gefährlich und das was
herr maske rechtsberater gesagt hat
nämlich dass es gibt keine andere von
all diesen vielen höchst fragwürdige
positionen und politik in form
versichern die so viel unterstützung in
der amerikanischen öffentlichkeit im
kongress hat wie eine harte haltung
gegenüber iran und dann macht das
gefährlich es ist nicht umstritten
das heißt dass atom abkommen und
generell die haltung gegen die rahmen
hat breite grundlage und das ist
historisch bedingt
das ist an sich wie eine zerrüttete ehe
die seit 40 jahren sich gegenseitig auf
vorwürfen beruht auf amerikanischer
seite die geiselnahme 19 79 während
daran mit der iranischen revolution auf
iranischer seite
der putsch von amerika und england 1953
gegen ministerpräsident sadek mossadegh
und in dieser zeit gab es da kann man
sagen man könnte eine linie zeichnen von
kooperative und aggressiver politik
haltung beider seiten und es gab ganz
wenige phasen wo diese haltung
beidseitig in der kooperation waren und
das war unter obama dort gab es das
lokal abkommen seit der stürze ist
wieder rein oder zuvor waren die ein
oder die andere nicht bereit und diese
chance wurde jetzt zerstört über den
ausstieg von trump aus dem nuklearen
kommen wie kommt der strom dass das
nicht umstritten jetzt ändern usa das
ist so klar ist dass man da ja das ist
schon umstritten
diese kriegsdrohungen da gibt es
überhaupt keine unterstützung für einen
kollegen ivan momentan natürlich gibt es
böses blut in den usa gegenüber
70 aber es gibt auch millionen von
iranern den usa auf wohnen und es ist
nicht so schwarz weiß wenn schon krieg
gegen ivan fühlen möchte dann braucht
der kongress dann braucht unterstützung
und dass das gibt es nicht es gibt viele
viele viele leute die denken och dann
2003 mit irak und die denken dass wir
werden uns nicht so wieder eingezogen
ansehen lassen
und auch jetzt gibt vergleich in den us
medien momentan mit den golf auftanken
damals mit in vietnam was von vielen
kriege führt das heißt ich glaube viele
leute in den märkischen hellwach und die
werden nicht einfach in einen krieg
hineingezogen werden und darf ja auch
nicht vergessen es gab ein paar
anschläge in dem persischen golf letzte
woche dass das kreiert hat es gibt auch
angebliche informationen dass iran was
vorhatte mit raketen aufboten geladen
haben
es ist nicht ohne da das ist nicht ein
friedliches freundliches land ist nur
gutes zu tun will
sie war schon ein gefährliches pflaster
also das war das ist hier die frage
diese bedrohungslage wird ja
unterschiedlich eingeschätzt
mascolo wenn man sagt wenn man hört zum
beispiel aus dem großbritannien der
general wieker der kommandeur gegen die
igs der sie keine erhöhte gefahr
das ist übertrieben also wie kommt man
das ist ja schwierig das wirklich
einzuschätzen
also sagen wir was ist die was steckt
dahinter dass man dann sagt man erhöht
die militärische präsenz
also ich glaube nach dem was man
jedenfalls muss man glaube ich
vorsichtig sein in diesem stadium aber
nach dem was man habe ich einschätzen
kann ist dass es auf amerikanischer
seite aber auch auf europäischer seite
eine sehr große zurückhaltung gibt ob
das was teile der amerikanischen
administration jetzt als bedrohung
beschreiben tatsächlich eine solche ist
nun ist es auch immer ganz schwer
auseinanderzuhalten
ob sich eigentlich die radikalen kräfte
innerhalb des iranischen regimes von
denen es nun ehrlich gesagt mehr als
genug gibt ob die sich nun vorbereiten
darauf dass die usa möglicherweise zu
schlagen oder ob die amerikaner
ebensolche vorbereitungshandlungen sehen
und sagen guck mal die bereiten sich
schon vor etwas gegen uns zu unternehmen
das macht ja genau die situation so
außerordentlich
gefährlich so dass man sich eigentlich
nur wünschen kann dass beide seiten
einen schritt zurücktreten aber selbst
wenn dir das jetzt erleben würden wir
waren gerade bei der sanktionspolitik
ich glaube dass da drin das wahre unheil
liegt dass die usa sind ja inzwischen
nicht mehr damit zufrieden dass sie wenn
sie beispielsweise eine andere
iran-politik wollen dass sie sagen die
setzen wir mit unseren eigenen
wirtschaftlichen und diplomatischen
mitteln durch und dann wir erleben ja
eine neue form von sanktionspolitik wo
die amerikaner über sogenannte sekundäre
sanktionen im grunde auch versuchen den
gesamten rest der welt europa
beispielsweise zu einer unterstützung
ihrer politik zu zwingen mit der wir
aber die bundesregierung beispielsweise
überhaupt nicht einverstanden ist also
diese diese methode die angewandt wird
zu sagen wir sorgen dafür dass all das
was ihr gegenüber dem iran versprochen
hat handelsbeziehungen der aufnahme der
finanzbeziehungen wieder das können im
grunde die europäer überhaupt nicht mehr
abliefern weil der starke arm amerikas
der dollar sie daran einfach hindert das
ist eine form glaube ich von
machtausübung die wir in der
vergangenheit so auch gar nicht kannten
wir haben ja auch in der vergangenheit
immer mal differenzen mit den usa über
einzelne politische fragen gehabt aber
dass man hinterher versucht die engsten
verbündeten im grunde mit hilfe von
wirtschaftssanktionen auf linie zu
zwingen ist etwas von dem ich glaube das
ist großen schaden aufsicht anrichten
würden liegt es an der stärke der usa
oder an der schwäche der europäer dass
ihr das ja also vielleicht auch noch wie
die wirken nicht die wirken durch eine
diffuse haltung der amerikaner
gewiss sagen ja nicht ganz genau was ist
all auf dass es verboten sondern sagen
schon das alles ist verboten
aber die drohung ist passt auf jeder
damit der iran irgendwelche geschäfte
macht könnte er in zukunft unter
probleme bekommt man wenn man an den
amerikanern seit moment das habt ihr
aber nicht explizit verboten
dann sagen sie naja schauen wir mal und
es geht darum wirtschaft es geht um
firmen und die firmen sind äußerst
zurückhaltend
die möglichkeiten auf dem amerikanischen
markt zu gefährden durch irgendwelche
geschäfte heute die für die sie später
bestraft werden
banken sind äußerst zurückhaltend
irgendetwas zu tun in der gefahr die
banklizenz in amerika zu verlieren also
da wirkt einfach eine diffuse haltung
sehr bedrohlich mit dem dass gerade der
mascolo gesagt hat nämlich die
ausdehnung imperialer sanktionspolitik
auf alle anderen dann kann die
unternehmen verstehen iran hat eine
wirtschaftsleistung von thorsten es ist
so groß wie borst in ungefähr so die
durch deutsche firmen europäische wir
haben viel zu verlieren wenn die in den
usa dann nicht mehr handeln dürften
natürlich so ist es ja was meint ihr wie
meinen sie das jetzt das ganze dann halt
nur zu starke wirtschaftliche der gebiet
austria allein ja so die usa ist viel
wichtiger für deutsche unternehmen aus
iran und deswegen sind die gewässer
es ist weniger die euro regierungen in
europa die zu schwach sind sondern die
firmen wollen offen offener märkte in
den usa weiterhin haben jetzt haben sie
ihm gesagt tram parteien kein interesse
an einem krieg hat seinen
sicherheitsberater verboten hat der
interesse daran
anscheinend schon der weg seit 20 jahren
drüber aus der un botschafter war aus
der fox kommentator war da hat irgendwas
mit iran
der war auch eine der falken in irak der
ist eine der leute die heute immer noch
sagt irak war wichtig die entscheidung
der einmarsch ihren job hat anscheinend
sex in zielitz mobil zu reden mit den
führenden leuten iran der hat immer
wieder botschaften geschickt werden ein
0 4 aus iran machen etwa mit den reden
und behandlung mehr zu männer denkt dass
es seine strategie er kann vielleicht
was handel und der große friedensmacht
ist sein boten boten waren hat es nicht
funktioniert haben
ich denke die ira niveau und dass die
usa wieder in den
abkommen kommt wie vor die mit den
amerikanerinnen aber wer weiß aber schon
probiert anscheinend ganz schön viel mit
denen direkt kontakt auf sony aber ist
das die richtige haltung vor ihrer dass
man sagt man redet eben nicht mit ihnen
weil man dieser bedrohung oder sollte
oder diesen dadurch dass die amerikaner
ausgestiegen ist
den kann man gar nicht nachgehen oder
müsste man sagen okay trump ist eben
kramt er ist eben anders und bei
nordkorea kommt irgendwie auch voran
wäre das sinnvoll dann doch um den
konflikt nicht weiter eskalieren zu
lassen zu sagen okay wir versuchen da
irgendwo einen dialog tatsächlich sind
die iraner äußerst pragmatisch das heißt
das hätte sehr wohl eine chance gegeben
ob nun über tecchannel kanäle oder auf
anderem wege mit den amerikanern
indirekte gespräche zu treten aber ich
glaube diese chance das absolut vertan
worden
wir sehen jetzt heute eine situation in
der es selbst für kräfte innerhalb derer
die sich für gespräche einsetzen wollen
würden immer schwerer wird nichts zu tun
vor allen dingen nicht öffentlich gerade
auch aufgrund der äußerung von donald
trumps selbst die das erheblich
erschwert und aufgrund des umstands dass
die amerikaner seit einem jahr ganz
offenkundig sich nicht mehr an die
vereinbarungen halten den sanktionsdruck
stück für stück erhöhen nicht nur der
wirtschaftsführer sondern auch in
anderen bereichen und für ihre haben
sich natürlich die frage gestellt wenn
wir uns jetzt auf gespräche einlassen
was kann dabei herauskommen was länger
bestand hätte als ein atom vereinbarung
denn letztlich haben sie sich ja schon
auf einen kompromiss eingelassen sie
haben sich auf dieses experiment
verhandlungen mit den usa eingelassen
und hier haben sie ein ergebnis gesehen
dass ihnen zeigt wir halten uns waren
das abkommen es hat washington dennoch
nicht davon abgehalten auszutreten
das heißt jedes folgeabkommen jede folge
vereinbarung hätte keinen bestand die
garantie die sicherheit ist schlicht
nicht da
das heißt aber nicht dass tiere nicht
potenzielle unter einer neuen
us-administration vielleicht zu anderen
gesprächen bereit habe das klingt jetzt
so also das vertrauen so zerrüttet ist
dass da gar nichts mehr geht der goalie
man das doch dann die stunde der
diplomaten dann irgendwie noch mal
anzufangen
also jetzt aus ihrem diplomatischen
leben gesprochen und sie haben im iran
auch die die amerikanische interessen
mit wahrgenommen also wie wie fängt man
da an wie könnte man da anfangen nicht
in der haltung von trump ist seine
sticks and carrots das heißt knüppel und
karotte
und man lässt sich halt mich gerne als
esel behandelt nicht
das sind instrumente mit denen geht man
mit einem esel und nicht mit einem
zivilisierten land und das ganz
wichtiges ist eigentlich der respekt der
respekt war entscheidend als ich glaube
es war 19 2003 drei außenminister
england deutschland frankreich
gleichzeitig so quasi an den hof der
amerikanischen regierung gereist sind
und das war der auslöser dass dann die
gespräche in gang haben dh für die
iraner ist etwas ganz entscheidend und
das heißt im gegenseitigen respekt und
ich habe einmal in washington gesagt sie
ist einfach wichtig dass sie drei wörter
aussprechen in milte respekt die antwort
war wie talent respekt ja dann habt ihr
ein problem
also ich hier abgesehen verlieren was
sie gesagt haben die frage ist es
überhaupt möglich
auf der ebene respektvollen umgangs mit
den iran ins gespräch zu kommen das war
ja der fall im nuklear abkommt und die
amerikaner sind ausgestiegen obwohl die
iraner nicht das abkommen verletzt haben
trump athletic gesagt sie verletzten den
geist der geist ist nicht ein
völkerrechtliches kategorie mit dem mann
recht fertig kann der andere hat den
vertrag verletzt und darf man aber auch
sagen dass iran auch zum beispiel
gegenüber israel eine klare bedrohung
aus steckt es ist ja nicht so dass als
sei alles sehen und dabei wir sind in
einer region wo sich alle gegenseitig
bedroht es gibt überhaupt nicht iran als
sehr gut und die anderen schlicht
erstellen
aber es gab in dieser ganzen gemengen
lage die erinnerung explosiv ist
übernimmt ihre haben die rolle eines
sündenbocks dh es ist unheimlich
kompliziert und man braucht einen wo man
sagen kann der ist schuld
und da sind sich alle einig die israelis
die amerikaner die saudis die emirate
etc
und man ist sich einig okay das war doch
dann die stunde der europäer
eigentlicher mascolo dass die sagen okay
wenn da alles so verhärtet ist das
vertrauen ist dahin müsste dann nicht
europa damit irgendwo hinkommen und
sagen wir versuchen dazu vermitteln oder
ist das auch nach
ja das ist gar nicht in einer so
zugespitzten situation kann man dazu gar
nicht nein sagen und sagen jeder der
irgendeine möglichkeit hat zu vermitteln
der soll es versuchen und um himmels
willen auch die europäer
ich glaube allerdings dass das in dieser
situation nicht viel bringen wird weil
mein eindruck ist dass die europäer ja
auch selber überhaupt nicht wissen woran
sie im moment eigentlich sinn mit den
usa also wenn wir uns anschauen dem
guldimann hat gerade gesagt den
berühmten satz in den usa sticks and
carrots also knüppel und karotte von
bolten gibt es den schönen satz karotten
mache ich nicht so man eigentlich nur
knöpfe okay das heißt bei john bolton
und auch bei manchem was man von dem
außenminister pompeo hört das ist in
wahrheit die alte bush und cheney schule
das klingt nach regime change und wann
immer man den eindruck hat dass man im
grunde zurück ist bei der achse des
bösen und bei dieser betrachtung der
welt hört man wiederum setze da geht es
dann so einen halben schritt zurück und
dann gibt es den präsidenten selbst von
dem ich tatsächlich glaube dass er
keinen militärischen konflikt sucht und
will der sagt ruf mich doch nur an und
lasst uns doch mal reden und ich würde
auf der anderen seite sagen dass hatte
er eigentlich gerade zweimal mit
nordkorea ausprobiert und wenn ich die
letzten meldungen richtig verfolgt habe
fliegen da wieder die raketen auch wenn
es irgendwie nur kurzstrecken raketen
sind also ist nordkorea jetzt der
grandiose erfolg gewesen wie man mit
solchen staaten umgeht
ich glaube es ist es nicht gewesen das
heißt die die schwierigkeit mit der es
glaube ich alle im moment zu tun haben
ist dass man das gefühl hat man weiß in
den usa auch gar nicht woran man
eigentlich ist und möglicherweise ist es
und das empfinde ich als die
gefährlichste situation weiß diese
administration selber auch gar nicht
ganz genau was sie da eigentlich im
moment macht wohin sie eigentlich will
dass sie eigentlich in allen richtungen
gleichzeitig unterwegs ist
unterschiedlichste signale aussendet man
kann ja im grunde nur vermitteln und
versuchen
lösungen zu finden wenn man eine klare
vorstellung davon hat was jetzt
beispielsweise die amerikanischen
erwartungen werden aber dann auch
gegenüber dem iran drängen
ja ich glaube das ist diese situation
sehr schwer helfen sie uns den punkt wo
man sagt da wollen die amerikaner
wirklich glaube schon dass ich ganz
offen und nie die stützen auf die was
die leute nie war eine auch sagen es
gibt anscheinend auch viel unterstützung
für wechsel aber und die sanktionen
greifen jetzt wie sie gesagt haben ganz
stark und schon glaubt dass es
erfolgreich weil dann diese ausstiegen
und die immer härtere sanktionen das
jetzt acht länder jetzt kein öl mehr
kaufen von iran
das zwingt ihren wirklichen die knien
und ich glaube schon dass die
us-regierung eine klare vorstellung hat
wie das gehen sollte dass die medien
hier also die wahl ein normales land ist
iran unterstützt ihre organisationen in
dem bereich des bürger- und so weiter
und so fort
ivan ist kein normales land und das
wünschen südamerikaner
das ist eines tages ein normales land
sein könnte wo die iranische studenten
wieder in den usa studieren können oder
europa das ist die hoffnung dass es die
erwartung wie er sich aus gehen wird das
ist ein ganz großartiges land ich bin
oft da gewesen und nichts würde ich mir
übrigens für die menschen mehr wünschen
als dass sie dieses mullah-regime
loswerden würden auf der anderen seite
ob die amerikaner dies irgendwie werden
erzwingen können auf dem weg da bin ich
nicht so sicher
ich würde mir übrigens auch wünschen
dass die nordkoreaner kim jong-un
loswerden
und ich habe auch noch nicht verstanden
warum donald trump zum beispiel sagt
dass er sich in kim jong-un verliebt hat
und dass er eben blühende landschaften
verspricht soweit er irgendwie nur seine
massenvernichtungswaffen auf gibt es ist
das wissen wir doch nun aus jahrzehnten
eine ungeheure herausforderung mit
solchen regimen umzugehen von denen wir
uns alle wünschen würden dass sie nicht
existieren und dass sie verschwinden und
ständig suchen wir nach lösungen dafür
der frage krieg zu führen aber ich
glaube man muss die welt sprechen sie
wie auf der achse des bösen nordkorea
irak saddam hussein und die rahmer das
sind die bösen im moment mal
also ich meine sie sagen sie haben
gesagt das ist ein terroristisches land
unterstützt das bedeute ein unternehmen
der saudi arabien seit jahrzehnten
unterstützen die saudis über ihre
moscheen salafitischen extremisten in
aller welt
sie haben den es unterstützt indirekt
nicht offiziell und das terrorproblem
dass wir haben immer ganzen region auf
der welt ist ein sunnitischer
extremistischer islamistischer
terrorismus mit dem mit anderen
gewaltpolitik hat dir an was zu tun aber
nicht mit dem wenn wir vom terrorismus
sprechen und dann kommt noch etwas dazu
wenn sie glauben dass es in iran wenn
man das so genannte mullah-regime ich
bin überhaupt nicht ein mich diese
bezeichnung lose würde dann blüht dort
die demokratie die gefahr ist dass die
destabilisierung des irans zur folge
haben kann dass wir ein zusätzliches
problem land haben das schwierig ist zu
kontrollieren mit enormen inneren
gegensätze ich bin dankbar für die
stabilität ihrer meinung nach eine gute
perspektive für das land
und was mit dem land helfen dem land
würde helfen dass es respektiert wird
also eine regionalmacht mit einem
respekt und einer lösung oder sagen wir
aber erleichterung der aussenbeziehungen
die es im innern erlaubt das regime zu
sagen wir mal demokratisieren es ist
immerhin in dem sie eine demokratisch
dass es dort präsidentschaftwahlen gibt
die etwas geburt sind aber immerhin das
resultat ist zufuhren nicht bekannt das
ist nicht die frage ob es freie wahl
gibt oder richtig aber es gibt viel mehr
politische gefangene in ägypten und
wahrscheinlich auch in saudi arabien
also in ihrem ja es gab nach nach china
aber in iran die meisten todesurteile
hinrichtungen frau sah mir ihre was
würde dem land gut und was mit dem
helfen zunächst einmal hätte es gut
getan werden wir die atomvereinbarung
hätten stabilisieren können wenn die
amerikaner nicht ausgestiegen wären dann
hätten wir eine grundlage gehabt auf der
wir weiter mit iran über andere dinge
hätten verhandeln können es gibt ja wie
schon mehrfach gesagt worden ist eine
ganze reihe von konfliktfeldern die nach
wie vor bestehen wo sich auch die usa
und die europäer eigentlich einig sind
was die konfliktfelder anbelangt das
betrifft nicht nur die
menschenrechtslage im land sondern auch
das ballistisches raketenprogramm irans
regionale aktivitäten hier gibt es eine
ganze reihe von herausforderungen die
man angehen müsste und die man heute
unter den derzeitigen bedingungen
schlicht lich sinnvoll angehen kann
zumindest nicht auf friedlichem wege
aufgrund des umstands dass wir eben
anatom vereinbarungen krisenmodus haben
und wenn diese vereinbarung auseinander
tatsächlich auseinander fällt wäre ja
zunächst einmal auch nichts gewonnen
die lösung für andere probleme dieser
lösung werden wir ein stück näher im
gegenteil wir hatten dann noch
zusätzlich eine beitrag krise die wir
bewältigen müssten dass es eigentlich im
moment auch das problem dem land hätte
das gut getan wenn wir auf dieser
grundlage weiter gegangen werden es gab
innenpolitische entwicklung die
begrüßenswert waren die regierung hat
die atomvereinbarung dazu genutzt um
einige wirtschaftliche reformvorhaben
durchzusetzen gegen korruption
vorzugehen unter anderem die rolle von
einflussreichen akteuren ihnen dieser
wirtschaftslehre zu begrenzen um
ausländische direktinvestitionen ins
land zu holen
also dinge die durchaus der transparenz
der entwicklung in diesem land gut getan
hätten
dass es eine hochgebildete gut
ausgebildete gesellschaft die sehr viel
potenzial hat wo sehr viel sozialer
bewegungen sind die aktiv sind die
versuchen sich für ihre eigenen rechte
einzusetzen
wir haben eher ihre entwicklung im land
ein stück weit zurückgeworfen
indem wir durch die entwicklung der
letzten zwölf monate radikale kräfte und
hardliner in diesem land stark gemacht
haben und die sozusagen
bewegungsfreiraum für die kräfte die
noch etwas mehr hätten bewegen können im
land also euren gegen einen regime
change wäre nicht das ihrer meinung nach
was gut wäre mit sicherheit nicht regime
change nicht auf dem wege der externen
intervention regime change kann schritt
für schritt durch entwicklung innerhalb
ihrer hans entstehen aber sicherlich
nicht durch militärische intervention
oder und darauf scheint hier eher die
top administration zu setzen
man erpresst quasi oder nimmt die
iranische bevölkerung in geiselhaft und
hoffe dass es irgendwann so schlecht
geht dass sie selbst das regime auf
diese war
stürzt und dieses kalkül wird auf diese
weise jedenfalls nicht aufgeben
kommen wir aber nochmal daher wenn das
so nicht funktioniert und wir da in
beiden seiten festgefahren sind die
fragen die ich vorhin schon mal gestellt
habe welche rolle kann europa da spielen
herr kirsch waren was nehmen die
amerikaner die überhaupt
aber wie wird davon von den usa aus
drauf geschaut werden wie wird er in
europa überhaupt ernst genommen
naja natürlich schon ich glaube weil
europa mit merkt man den sanktionen
haben die sanktionen ein großer wirkung
gehabt
aber das sollen die europäer fragen aber
erstens möchte ich sagen ich bin nicht
für regime change ich berichte nur weil
es aus den usa kommen nicht dass ich
plötzlich pranger gestellt aber ich
glaube die europäer können die frage
beantworten weil ich glaube es gibt ein
fenster jetzt von 60 tagen iran und das
ist glaube ich ein signal das ist jetzt
die stunde für die europäer vielleicht
möglichkeiten für diese hübsche all
diese ist tags diese finanzen
finanzierungssystem damit handel
passieren kann ohne die amerikaner aber
das ist jetzt die zeit der europäer
vielleicht was auf die beine zu bringen
er macht überhaupt niemanden der als man
den iranern versprochen hat dass man den
handel absichern würde habe ich in
dieser stadt und auch anderswo in europa
eigentlich nur leute getroffen die mit
augenzwinkern gesagt haben wir wissen
dass das letztlich gar nicht möglich ist
dafür ist der amerikanische einfluss in
der sache dann doch zu groß
ich glaube allerdings dass die iraner
eigentlich auch ziemlich genau wussten
wo die limits der europäer in der sache
liegen würden
kann man das jetzt innerhalb der
nächsten 60 oder 550 tage die wir jetzt
da noch haben das ändern
das kann man nicht aber ich glaube dass
die jetzige entwicklung innerhalb
europas die frage schon in gang gesetzt
hat was man langfristig eigentlich tun
muss damit man nicht morgen die nächste
gelegenheit hat wir diskutieren ja ich
will jetzt hier keinen ort stehen zwei
diskussion aufmachen aber die frage wo
wir dann solche sanktion sun drohungen
der usa in der zukunft erleben werden
vor allem bei einem solchen präsidenten
oder wir jemanden der das irgendwie
ähnlich betrachten mag der kongress ist
ja ähnlich gewählt solche sanktionen
einzusetzen
das hat bei den europäern eine menge
überlegungen in gang gesetzt wie man
sich unabhängiger machen
gibt es jetzt eine kurzfristige lösung
kurzfristig etwas was europa tatsächlich
tun kann wo es einfluss nehmen kann
an der stelle bin ich pessimistisch sind
zwei ebenen
das eine ist die wirtschaftliche ebene
dass ich es genauso
es ist enorm schwierig für die europäer
die dinge zu liefern gegen iran die
versprochen worden sind im irak im
nuklear abkommen an dem die europäer
festhalten wollen
die haben da lange festgehalten haben
und jetzt ankündigen wahrscheinlich ist
nicht mehr zu beachten
das heißt wirtschaftlich angesichts des
amerikanischen drucks zu liefern
gegenüber den iranern ist sicher
schwierig aber was man machen kann ist
die politische ebene und ich glaube die
wurde viel zu wenig gespielt seitens der
europäer
denn es geht nicht nur um die europäer
es geht auch in russland china
das heißt es notwendig gegenüber iran
ein signal zu setzen
mit den russen und den chinesen zusammen
um zu sagen es ist nicht das problem
ihrer ansicht ist das problem mit der
amerikanischen administration und wir
zusammen versuchen wie wir damals
zusammen mit dem amerikaner gemacht
haben auf politischer ebene gegenüber
iran aktiv zu werden ist schwierig ja da
geht es auch um die beziehung mit
russland und die beziehung mit china
aber zu sehen dass die iraner jetzt ja
quasi sich überlegen können wir uns nach
asien orientieren auch wirtschaftlich
demgegenüber ging es jetzt darum zu
sagen europäer russen und chinesen
versuchen die amerikanische politik
zumindest auf politischer ebene also
wollen sie sagen die europäer müssen in
richtung usa wirken und weniger in
richtung gefahren
die europäer sollten gegen die
amerikaner in der sanktionspolitik die
ja nicht nur iran sondern noch ganz
andere dinge betrifft aktiv werden und
hat haben dafür die möglichkeit im falle
von iran mit den chinesen und den russen
zusammenzugehen für gemeinsame treffen
wie schaut man vom iran aus nach europa
was erhofft man sich da vielleicht noch
mal war ich das doch wichtig finde es zu
sagen es gibt noch mit ganze reihe von
dingen die wir jetzt tun können erst
einmal die 60 tage sind nicht relevant
es wird mich dann in 60 tagen hängen wir
wären über die 60 tage gegebenfalls
drüber gehen das wird noch nicht dazu
führen dass die atomvereinbarung
automatisch auseinanderfällt
das problem das wir gerade haben ist
folgendes die usa haben seit mai auch
den export von nuklearmaterialien
sanktioniert dh den export von schwer
wasser den export von leicht
angereichertem uran
nun sieht die atomvereinbarung aber vor
dass die lagerung dieser
nuklearmaterialien der bestand dieser
nuklearmaterial eine bestimmte
obergrenze nicht überschreiten
vielleicht einfach noch mal irgendwer
iran darf maximal 300 kilo uran und
130.000 tonnen schwer was im land
behalten den rest muss er ausführt aber
diese ausfuhr ist jetzt die ausfuhr ist
sanktioniert das heißt iran wird jetzt
nicht nur wirtschaftspolitische isoliert
sondern aktiv darin eingeschränkt seinen
eigenen verpflichtungen der
atomvereinbarung nachzukommen
was iran jetzt gemacht hat ist quasi den
spieß umzudrehen und zu sagen okay wir
verlangen jetzt dass ihr eine lösung für
dieses problem findet denn wir werden
dann schlicht selbst nicht mehr
exportieren das heißt es kann sein dass
wir den kommenden 60 tagen über diese
obergrenze hinübergehen und damit
verstoßen und wir verlangen dass ihr das
auch nicht als verstoß deklariert und
dass es eine ganz heikle situation und
die gibt es verschiedene dinge die wir
tun können
die oberste priorität muss jetzt haben
zu verhindern dass es überhaupt zu einem
verstoß kommen nochmal noch sind wir
nicht an dem punkt dass die iraner gegen
das abkommen verstoßen haben sobald die
internationale atomenergiebehörde
feststellt dass es zu einem
signifikanten verstoß gekommen ist
brauchen wir gar nicht mehr zu
diskutieren dann ist die
atomvereinbarung am ende und wenn das
dann das heißt doch was würde das
bedeuten und das bedeutet zum einen dass
wir eine größere eskalationsgefahr haben
dann gibt es so mögliche folgen wie
einen nuklearen wettlauf im persischen
golf und darüber hinaus die gefahren
gezielte militärschläge gegen iranische
atomanlagen die auch wiederum zu einer
militärischen eskalation führen können
die gefahr dass iran ganz aus dem npt
austritt beispielsweise wie nordkorea
damals und dann vielleicht ein will und
die dann vielleicht sozusagen eine ganz
andere entwicklung nehmen aber nochmal
den punkt war das wichtig ist was wir
jetzt als erstes tun müssen um diesen
verstoß zu verhindern
wir müssten die drei gemeinsam mit den
außenministern chinas russlands und der
eu aus
auftrag für die kategorie erst mal ein
zeichen setzen indem er nach deren
reisen sowie es wie wir es 2003 gemacht
haben das war der anfang das ist
sinnvoll dass die europäer jetzt dahin
stark im gepäck zu sagen wir nehmen euch
diese nuklearmaterialien ab damit leben
nicht gegen das abkommen verstößt und
wir haben im gepäck eine klare roadmap
die zeit dass wir zwar nicht in den
folgenden 60 tagen die notwendigen
weichen stellen können um sozusagen
wirtschaftlich derart unabhängig zu
agieren wie wir es eigentlich schon
längst können sollten aber die
weichenstellung mit konkreten
vorschlägen wie in den nächsten 3 15
jahren jeden dieser autonomie erreicht
werden kann
das hätte eine signalwirkung den iran
und ich denke das signal sollte er in
den iran aber natürlich auch eine
signalwirkung in die usa was würde das
dann für das transatlantische verhältnis
bedeutende kirschbaum
ja das kommt den gefährliche brisante
bereich minato und so weiter und sofort
klar aber ich glaub die usa ist
zufrieden dass die sanktionen so
wirkungsvoll sind dass das verleiht als
80 prozent der menschen schlecht geht ja
genau das dass der druck auf der siemens
erhöht wurden
es gibt berichte aus den usa dass dies
ohne wartet erfolgreich diese sanktionen
zeit seit einem jahr und von daher in
europa hier frieden schaffen kann und
ganz schön ist ich glaube das ist nicht
ein problem ist kein problem völlig im
maracana die wollen wirklich kein krieg
gemeint ist es jetzt
es kommt in den medien hier in europa in
deutschland das ist kein krieg aber es
sind so viele leute so viel gelernt seit
dem irak-krieg und kongresse man liest
was die kongress und diakon ist sage
keiner will ein krieg und alle beweise
ganz harte beweise sehen was für
intelligenz und service
es ist wirklich weit davon entfernt
einen krieg zu kommen jetzt ja mascolo
was denken sie wieder was das für die
amerikaner bedeuten würde wenn die
europäer sich so verhalten würden wie
wir aus amerika das eben beschreibt und
nach teheran fahren würden das ist der
wahrscheinlich härteste
interessengegensatz zwischen europa und
in der sache muss man sagen anders als
bei ihrer klage muss wo die europäer
auseinander gelaufen sind was sie ja
üblicherweise fast immer tun wenn es um
solche großen außenpolitischen fragen
gehen kann man bei iran sehen dass
europa ganz fest beieinander steht und
sagt wir halten die amerikanische
politik für grundfalsch
das auswärtige amt hat das ja sogar sehr
früh schon mal die formulierung der
roten linie gebraucht die die usa in der
sache nicht überschreiten dürfen rote
linie ist das dass präsident obama mal
in bezug auf syrien und den einsatz von
giftgas als formulierung gebraucht hat
das ist hier einer der härtesten
interessengegensätze und ich halte die
europäische position für viel wichtiger
als die amerikanische das heißt in der
sache wird es gar nicht anders gehen als
den amerikanern bei aller freundschaft
zu sagen wir halten ihre positionen und
eure politik für falsch und für
gefährlich wird es am ende dazu führen
die diesen präsidenten von seiner
politik abzuhalten von der ich immer
noch sagen kann ich kann so genau nicht
erkennen wie sie eigentlich im aussieht
ich teile irgendwie ihren eindruck der
amerikanische außenminister pompeo hat
es ja schon mit der untergehenden
sowjetunion verglichen und hat gesagt
das sind im grunde ganz ähnliche
prozesse
die menschen werden unzufrieden
wirtschaftlich und zufrieden und dann
kann man sich darauf verlassen
dann werden sie sich irgendwann schon
auflehnen und dann bekommen wir freie
und demokratische verhältnisse ich kann
ihnen nur sagen ich würde ich würde mir
wünschen dass es genau so einfach wäre
und so ausginge aber ich fürchte so
einfach wird es nicht ausgehen europa
muss den usa ganz klar sagen
das hier wie tals der europäische
interessen betroffen sind und dass die
usa hier nicht auf europäische
unterstützung sondern auf europäischen
widerstand treffen aber es ist natürlich
schwierig weil das zum atom abkommen
gehören hat eben auch russland und china
also was das heißt das ja wohl jemand
was zuerst da diplomatisch ich glaube
ich würde mir europäische emanzipation
von der behaupteten transatlantischen
freundschaft die nicht mehr existiert
dass man endlich mal sagt man erkennt es
gibt diese transatlantische freundschaft
in dem sinne wie sie als widerstand
wirken könnte gegenüber einer haltung
einer harten haltung die habe mascolo
gesagt hat in ihrem diese freundschaft
gibt es nicht mehr und ich kann wenn das
möglich ist und europa fähig ist
selbstständig aus dem politik zu
betreiben gegenüber iran zusammen mit
russland um hier in diesem fall es gibt
andere dinge liebe radio alleine kann
man sich nicht verständigen
okay aber das ist notwendig um versionen
gibt für die europäer wie sie jetzt auch
davon aus es wird behauptet von
europäischer seite dass man alles daran
setzt gegenmaßnahmen gegen solche
sanktionen zu ergreifen
das eine ist wie gesagt das
wirtschaftlich besonders das politische
im politischen bereich kann man was tun
und hier wird zu wenig gemacht
ich weiß nicht ich meine die
wirtschaftsunternehmen in europa die wir
uns sehr schnell einknicken ich bin sehr
schnell die regierung in dringend zu
handeln guck mal was in die schweiz
basiere hat mit der bankgeheimnisse dass
die amerikaner gedroht haben
nicht mehr dass die schweiz das hat
nicht lange gedauert und ich glaube die
usa für gute oder schlechte gründe hat
diese macht mit die wirtschaftliche
verflechtungen zwischen europa und usa
und ich glaube die freundschaft zwischen
europa und usa ist ist immer noch sehr
stark
es hat ein paar vielleicht knicks
bekommen jetzt mit dieser minister
aktionen aber das dauert vielleicht nur
noch eineinhalb jahren wer weiß aber die
die die die beziehungen die verhältnis
zwischen usa in europa ist sehr sehr
stark so schnell kann man das nicht
abtun dass sich freundschaft ist tot
der ist ja dass sie sie würde das nicht
so sehen auf wen setzen sie hoffnung vor
samuel rat gibt es jemanden auf frau
margarine auf den deutschen
außenminister immerhin ist deutschland
jetzt hat den sitz im sicherheitsrat
in bezug darauf in bezug auf das ist
jetzt anders
das ist dass sich etwas bewegt das jetzt
irgendwie jemand versucht innerhalb
diesen 60 tagen die jetzt dastehen so
sagen wir wir müssen irgendwo versuchen
diesen konflikt wirklich ja wieder zu
deeskalieren
wie gesagt ich glaube dass die europäer
jetzt einfach an die drei zusammen mit
der eu außenbeauftragten aber in enger
koordination mit russland und china die
gehören eben auch zu dieser vereinbarung
das sind ganz wichtige partner auch für
iran in der wirtschaftslehre zusammen
handeln können in entlang der vorschläge
die ich vorher in einige von denen habe
ich aufgeworfen dargelegt habe dass es
möglich ich sehe wenig potenzial bis
nahezu gar kein potenzial wenn es darum
geht auf kurze sicht irgendwie in dieser
wirtschaftslehre voranzukommen wieder
mit ins tags der zweckgesellschaft die
wird schlicht nicht reichen noch in
bezug darauf dass die europäer in der
lage wären innerhalb der nächsten 60
tage quasi ölexporte möglich zu machen
oder ähnliches das wird schlicht nicht
funktionieren aber die weichenstellung
dafür zu legen einen glaubwürdigen
klaren teheran vorzulegen wo es ja auch
nicht nur im iran geht im grunde geht es
uns ja nicht um ihre arme es geht ja
allgemein um europäische
handlungsfähigkeit in der außenpolitik
um strategische autonomie von berlin
erreicht beweisen könnte dass wir einen
punkt der uns bevorsteht wir uns noch
ganz andere herausforderungen
bevorstehen
hier kann man auch handeln aber es gibt
bereiche wo europäische sozusagen
kapazitäten begrenzt sind noch aber das
heißt nicht dass wir diese kapazitäten
nicht in den nächsten jahren entwickeln
könnten oder nicht sollten
wir denken ja wie denkt man in der
bevölkerung habe ich darüber oder bei
den studenten oder indem sie wird
darüber gedacht in der iranischen
bevölkerung gibt es einen extrem hohen
frust auch die zuspruchs rate
beispielsweise für die atomvereinbarung
hat ja massiv abgenommen die lag 2015
noch bei über 70 jetzt sind es
vielleicht knapp die hälfte der iraner
die überhaupt noch einen sinn oder
mehrwert darin sehen hier zu verbleiben
und die sind auch enttäuscht von den
europäern es gibt ja genügend stimmen
die sagen dass ja schön und gut dass die
europäer ankündigen sie würden uns
helfen wollen aber de facto kommt uns ja
nicht zugute all die maßnahmen die
europäer getroffen haben wie ihren wert
sind haben ja de facto nichts an den
lebensumständen des iranischen bürger
verändert oder verbessert sind am ende
der sendung hergolding und es tut mir
leid ich weiß dass wir hier noch weiter
darüber sprechen könnten also ganz
herzlichen dank für nämlich dass der
europäer da irgendwie stärker sich
aufstellen müssen vielen dank für die
diskussion vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und bei uns natürlich wie immer um 23
uhr mesz phoenix der tag heute begleitet
sie meine kollegin konstanzer abwärts
gehen bis dahin
[Musik]